Avery Kim: Today’s focus: catalog bulk import.
Samira López: Any blockers from last time?
Avery Kim: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Samira López: Coordinate with SRE for rollout on catalog bulk import.
Samira López: Risk: accessibility gaps for catalog bulk import.
Avery Kim: Coordinate with SRE for rollout on catalog bulk import.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on catalog bulk import; start with a spike.
Riley Chen: From design side, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Samira López: Action: set up dashboards.
Priya Singh: From QA perspective, We might need a migration.
Noah Williams: Let’s capture action items clearly on catalog bulk import.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on catalog bulk import; parallelize testing.
Priya Singh: Observability dashboards for errors on catalog bulk import.
Riley Chen: Risk: scope creep for catalog bulk import.
Riley Chen: Action: write migration.
Samira López: Action: write migration.
Avery Kim: Risk: flaky tests for catalog bulk import.
Jordan Patel: We’ll need QA test cases listed on catalog bulk import.
Priya Singh: Action: write migration.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on catalog bulk import; ship a thin slice.
Noah Williams: I think we split catalog bulk import into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Observability dashboards for errors on catalog bulk import.
Samira López: Let’s not block on catalog bulk import; start with a spike.
Jordan Patel: My take is we split catalog bulk import into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Infra-wise, Tests should cover unhappy paths.
Avery Kim: Action: set up dashboards.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on catalog bulk import; parallelize testing.
Avery Kim: Action: write migration.
Riley Chen: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on catalog bulk import.
Priya Singh: Risk: flaky tests for catalog bulk import.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on catalog bulk import; start with a spike.
Samira López: I think we split catalog bulk import into two subtasks.
Samira López: I propose we split catalog bulk import into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: Risk: flaky tests for catalog bulk import.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on catalog bulk import; parallelize testing.
Jordan Patel: From QA perspective, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Avery Kim: Quick update on the scope on catalog bulk import.
Samira López: Action: set up dashboards.
Riley Chen: From QA perspective, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on catalog bulk import; ship a thin slice.
Jordan Patel: From design side, Design feedback is pending.
Noah Williams: Action: write migration.
Jordan Patel: Risk: flaky tests for catalog bulk import.
Samira López: Okay, who can take ownership?
Avery Kim: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Riley Chen: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.